في مقابله مع الجزيره قال مدير المكتب
الاعلامي الحكومي في غزه ان نحو مليون
ونصف مليون شخص في القطاع اصبحوا بلا ماوى
من جانب اخر نقلت ول ستريت جورنال عن
خبراء امريكيين اجروا تحليلا لبيانات
الاقمار الصناعيه من قطاع غزه ان 70% من
منازل القطاع تضررت او دمرت بالكامل وكشف
الخبراء ان الدمار في شمال غزه وحدها طال
80% من المباني اوضح تحليل ائتلاف الاغاثه
بالمج النرويجي للاجئين ان مهمه ازاله
الانقاض بعد الحرب ستستغرق سنه على الاقل
بسبب الاوضاع المعقده وصعوبه ازاله
الذخائر التي لم تنفجر بامان كما ان اعاده
بناء المساكن في القطاع ستتطلب من سبع
سنوات الى عشر اذا توفر التمويل حيث تقدر
تكلفه اعاده البناء بثلاثه مليارات ونصف
مليار
دولار